leaders of the pacific islands were
given a traditional fijian send-off as
their annual meeting came to an end they
stood united albeit down on numbers
after the withdrawal of kiribati that
decision and china's increased
diplomatic activity set the tone for a
gathering that was all about the many
pressures the region faces
these include a runaway climate crisis
socio-economic development challenges
slow economic growth and geopolitical
competition
we also know
that we cannot address these challenges
on our own
climate change has become interwoven
with the geopolitical rivalry between
china and the us playing out in the
pacific
these countries contribute little in the
form of carbon emissions but are feeling
the consequences and want more
international assistance
china is the world's largest emitter
while the largest member of the forum
australia is one of the biggest
exporters of fossil fuels the latest
science suggests that we need to see a
global cut in emissions by at least 50
percent this decade
so pacific island countries are calling
on all major emitters to be doing their
share to make sure that all pacific
island countries survive
now these nations are in a position
where they can use renewed interest in
their strategic value as leverage to get
what they want while there are concerns
among pacific island countries about the
geopolitical tension they're happy the
issues they're facing are receiving the
attention they deserve as a result what
they don't want is to be pushed into a
position where they have to choose sides
they're welcoming the economic and
security sweeteners coming their way but
they know that often those things don't
come for free most of these old
friendships remain strong but there's
plenty of concern about how much
pressure they might soon come under
wayne hey al jazeera suva